y significa esto que se recreó la
energía del Sol en un laboratorio En qué
consiste este avance científico sí
efectivamente es como tú lo dices se ha
recreado lo que ocurre en el sol es
decir que dos átomos livianos se
fusionan eso libera muchísima energía
como ocurre con el sol y es un gran
logro no solamente por el hecho en sí
sino también porque se ha logrado lo que
se llama una ganancia neta de energía es
decir sea liberado más energía que la
que han invertido en el proceso por eso
este momento el día de hoy es un hito en
materia de generación de energía porque
han logrado realizar algo que es muy
complicado hacerlo de manera controlada
con una ganancia neta de energía es
decir se ha liberado más energía que la
que se invirtió esto es un obviamente
estamos a décadas de lograr
que esto signifique energía barata para
todos pero es un hito importantísimo que
nos permite estar mucho más cerca de ese
momento que llegarán una década o dos
pero ahora sí estamos seguros de que es
posible bueno justo sobre eso le quería
preguntar y es que qué tan cerca estamos
de esa codiciada energía limpia porque
se habla de que en una década ya se
podría incluso desarrollar una planta de
fusión
Sí exactamente alrededor de entre una y
dos décadas seamos optimistas pensemos
que es en una esto significaría energía
no ilimitada no infinita Porque nada es
infinito pero prácticamente infinita es
decir cinco Diez mil veces más energía
que la energía nuclear de fisión que la
que actualmente existe que ya es cinco
mil veces Digamos que ya genera cinco
mil veces más energía por unidad de masa
que el carbón por ejemplo decir con una
central de tamaño medio se podía
alimentar toda Europa esto es no
solamente acceder a energía limitar sino
democratizarla porque ya no
dependeríamos de los países que tienen
la suerte de tener recursos fósiles en
su subsuelo cualquiera cualquier país
cualquier grupo humano cualquier
industria podrá tener energía de manera
muy sencilla sí es un gran en granito
bueno Y finalmente Entonces cuál sería
el paso siguiente en esta búsqueda para
que pueda ser utilizado a gran escala
bien los dos hitos Es una muy buena
pregunta porque los dos hitos eran Cómo
lograr generar más energía que la
invertida esto es ganancia neta esto ya
se alegró logró el segundo hito es como
hacerlo de manera barata digamos Es
decir de manera competitiva para lograr
eso todavía falta falta mucho están
hablando de una década década y media
para que esto pueda lograrse de manera
masiva se requiere que además sea barato
estamos todavía un poquito lejos de eso
pero para la humanidad diez años no es
tanto así que calculemos entre una beca
de una década y media va a ser
competitivo del punto de vista del costo